buonasera a tutti sono i questa giorgi
sono il presidente nazionale di aidaa
associazione italiana giovani avvocati
ho raccolto l'invito a partecipare
all'evento ted con estremo piacere anche
perché è stata un po una sfida quella di
avvicinare e di presentare a voi un
concetto di innovazione che è il filo
rosso di tutti gli interventi che ci
sono stati fino ad adesso e che
seguiranno fino alla fine la giornata
con il concetto di giustizia civile
italiana è un'operazione che so che per
molti non è facile non è facile perché
ci troviamo di fronte ad una giustizia
italiana di cui conosciamo benissimo le
lacune e soprattutto i tempi
particolarmente lunghi il sono qui per
parlare però di innovazione nella
giustizia civile parlando di pct
processo civile telematico
il processo civile telematico è un nuovo
modo di gestire all'interno dei
tribunali tutte le fasi legate al
processo civile ed è il nuovo modo è
dato da quello telematico rispetto a
quello cartaceo cui tutti avendo avuto a
che fare bene o male magari con un
avvocato
spero pochi per molti perché non siamo
una categoria molto apprezzata ma voglio
dire momento in cui si ha a che fare con
il tribunale con una causa il si ha a
che fare con il proprio fascicolo
ebbene il fascicolo oggi a un fascicolo
cartaceo e soprattutto è un fascicolo
che avrà una storia lunghissima si sa
quando si apre purtroppo spesso non si
riesce a capire quando si chiude con il
processo civile telematico si è voluto
introdurre oggi è a livello sperimentale
un nuovo metodo che va ad incidere sulla
produttività del tribunale su costi
ridotti e sulla trasparenza che cosa
intendo con questi tre concetti che sono
rientrati con il processo civile
telematico nel sistema giustizia
significa far fronte a delle richieste
prima tutte che provengono dall'europa
perché la lentezza dei nostri
procedimenti ha portato l'italia ad
essere destinataria di decine di
sanzioni a livello europeo
questo perché perché ogni persona ha
diritto che il proprio processo si è
svolto in maniera pubblica equa e in un
tempo ragionevole
ebbene l'italia non riesce oggi a
soddisfare questo terzo principio del
tempo ragionevole bene con il pct
abbiamo uno strumento per intervenire su
questo aspetto il pct oggi a livello
sperimentale e significa trasformare
quella che è un'operazione che viene
face to face all'interno dalle
cancellerie con il cancelliere con sé il
professionista che va a depositare gli
atti in un processo completamente
telematizzato è poi stato possibile dal
2007 siamo in fase sperimentale vi
dicevo è la dopo si vede 2007 iniziarlo
a milano dove oggi il processo civile
telematico almeno nella fase del
procedimento monitorio è quasi del tutto
completato
essendo una stata una cosa virtuosa e
fortunatamente le cose virtuose riescono
ad espandersi in maniera più o meno
virale dal 2007 altri tribunali hanno
raccolto l'idea di essere campioni
sperimentali del pct e dal 2007 in poi
si sono aggiunte altre città come
catania napoli palermo bologna rimini e
anche padova anche padova ed al 2008
città campione che sta provando ad
attuare il processo civile telematico
questo è stato possibile grazie anche ai
consigli degli ordini che hanno
consentito di individuare dei punti
d'accesso voi lo vedete in questo
slide il punto d'accesso consente di
passare direttamente dal professionista
con l'invio telematico al ministero
della giustizia il quale poi
distribuisce all'interno dei tribunali
addirittura si è nel 2011 dato che il
legislatore ha capito che era cosa buona
e giusta
addirittura addirittura tolto la
necessità di un punto di accesso
trasformando tutte le comunicazioni con
il sistema della pec è aumentato in via
esponenziale la possibilità di attuare
il processo civile telematico
che cosa significa questo significa che
oggi ci troviamo ancora in via nel
sistema ordinario a dover fare a dover
vedere impegnato il personale di
cancelleria i magistrati in fasi
necessariamente legate al passaggio
manuale di atti e documenti c'è stato
fino a poco tempo fa l'ufficiale
giudiziario che veniva all'interno dei
degli studi legali a notificare come un
semplice postino gli atti se non
parlassimo di numeri contenuti potremmo
immaginare che il rapporto personale non
debba essere eliminato a fronte di un
rapporto più freddo come quello
telematico ma non è così noi stiamo
parlando di milioni di atti che fino
all'altro giorno sono stati notificati a
mezzo mani e oggi invece possono essere
notificati tranquillamente via mail
quindi una maggiore produttività dei
soggetti che possono venire impegnati in
tutte le altre attività collaterali per
far funzionare il nostro sistema
giustizia
parlavo di numeri ed è anche legato ad
una ottimizzazione dei costi perché il
personale nell'attività che esso svolge
direttamente a livello di sportello
all'interno delle cancellerie comporta
necessariamente un costo
gli atti che sono stati notificati fino
all'altro giorno a mezzo pec superano il
milione e 200 mila atti gli atti che
sono stati depositati invece dal dagli
avvocati e all'interno dei tribunali con
il sistema sperimentale e quindi con un
intervento ancora di parte solo di parte
dei tribunali in tutta italia sono state
oltre 40.000 e questo a livello
sperimentale che cosa ha comportato
comportato che oggi non ci sono più
chi ha potuto depositare il livello
telematico il problema di fare tante
copie degli atti quanti sono chiaramente
le parti del del processo non è stato
più necessario pagare i diritti di copia
per le copie degli atti
ma è stato soprattutto possibile vedere
l'immediatezza di consultazione da parte
del professionista e non solo del
fascicolo telematico cosa è successo e
si è stato un risparmio di ben 42
milioni 501 mila e 858 euro
lo devo leggere anch'io perché volte ho
difficoltà a credere quale è il livello
di risparmio che il sistema giustizia
italiana può attuare con l'entrata a
regime del processo civile telematico e
quindi una riduzione dei costi ma quindi
anche non solo maggiore trasparenza
perché il processo civile telematico
consentirà non solamente all'avvocato e
al professionista quindi di poter
accedere verificare il deposito degli
atti i documenti poter quindi comunicare
questo proprio cliente nell'ottica di
una massima trasparenza
ma il privato cittadino chiunque di voi
avrà una causa in tribunale potrà con la
semplice applicazione gratuita giustizia
civile verificare costantemente lo stato
del proprio fascicolo potrà
costantemente verificare il deposito
degli atti quali sono gli atti qual è
stato il l'ultima attività svolta
rendersi conto di qual è il percorso di
un interesse che è stato dato in mano
all
allo stato per poter ottenere giustizia
un diritto che oggi è fondamentale e
proprio perché oggi è fondamentale
noi dobbiamo insistere perché il 30
giugno 2014 data che il nostro sistema
normativo ha previsto come data di
entrata in vigore ea regime del processo
civile telematico venga rispettata
questo è un seguito ed è importantissimo
non solamente per il sistema giustizia
ma per il paese ritengo che l'italia
debba vincere la sfida del processo
civile telematico e quindi è da qui da
dove si vuole far accendere il motore
del cambiamento e dell'innovazione che
io rivolgo una istanza molto forte lo
rivolgo alle istituzioni e al nuovo
ministro della giustizia perché faccia
in modo che il 30 giugno 2014 sia la
data dove anche l'italia potrà iniziare
a cambiare rotta potrebbe posso iniziare
ad avere un processo civile in tempi
ragionevoli e a tutto vantaggio del
cittadino
vi ringrazio